what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and and if you
have any topics that you want me to
cover please send them to my Instagram
just pearly things one that's just
pearly things one so
um today we have a lot of stuff we're
gonna go over we have um Psychology
today we have anti-suffragettes
um Tick Tock video
um we have a only fans model who died
trying to be a
um and a debate on Twitter about
should your husband do the dishes
um but before I start guys make sure you
leave a comment and let me know what
topics you want me to cover tomorrow and
next week so starting today
Psychology today
um has really gone off the chains in the
last couple of years you know when I was
younger I really thought that psychology
today was like a credible news source um
but the older I get the more I see it's
just
how women complaining about dating out
of their league that that's really what
it is as you guys know you know 100 of
women want 20 percent of men so what we
really see in Psychology today is a
bunch of run through chicks
psychoanalyzing
um the guys that really didn't like him
that much you know and we used to live
in a society where women could take L's
in peace you know what I mean like all
right you don't think our grandmothers
or great-grandmothers or
great-great-grandmothers took else
you don't think they ever batted a
little out of their league and you know
got their heart broke feelings hurt
whatever it was that totally happened
that absolutely happened the difference
is us women today
psychoanalyze and for a lifetime
and then make albums TV series whatever
it is just out of else you know men take
L's every day
but you don't really see like the men
writing an article
about that gold digger that you
know he was dating for six months and
realized was just there for his money so
now you know as I've said modern women
love to be cheated on now everybody
thinks I'm crazy for this opinion
they're like Pearl that's not true but I
just had the realization after doing
over a hundred episodes of my my show
the pre-game which I do on Thursday and
Friday nights
um where I would interview modern chicks
um
and I would just find that everybody
has a cheating ex-boyfriend so it's like
if we don't like cheaters why do we keep
picking them and it goes back to that we
keep dating out of our league and
whining so now this is a psychoanalysis
from some crazy lady I don't know who
wrote this but I guarantee it was a
chick so how to recognize micro cheating
in a relationship so we're to the point
where we are we're bitching about
micro cheating
the generation of women with asses on
Instagram that walk around half naked
are now
bitching about micro cheating so
my what is micro cheating you ask micro
cheating involves actions or behaviors
by your partner that make you question
their emotional or physical commitment
to your relationship so let me get this
straight
anything and this is the problem where
we tell women our feelings are valid
guys I am a woman and I will tell you we
have a million feelings every day and
ninety percent of the time they're
dramatic and they're not valid and the
problem is we have lied to women about
our nature so we tell us that we have
perfectly reasonable thoughts in all of
our our feelings are perfectly
reasonable when we're not reasonable
beings sorry guys we're just we're very
swayed by Propaganda we're very swayed
by our environment and our feelings
change every day so this idea that now
you're gonna at your boyfriend or
your husband from micro cheating because
you questioned
his emotional or physical commitment to
the relationship you know I've heard
guys say that they they cheat
because they're just so tired of their
woman bitching about cheating now I know
you guys you're thinking that's crazy
but let's try it let's try to go from
their point of view for a second
it's like every day if someone's
accusing you of stealing if did you rob
me did you rob me did you rob me it's
like by the hundredth time you're like I
might as well freaking rob you because
every day you're bitching about it
um and this is how a lot of men feel I'm
not saying it's okay but a lot of you
chicks are so crazy you drive men to
cheat and nobody wants to have this
conversation because honestly it makes
women look bad so
this can include actions like regularly
texting someone they find attractive or
obsessively liking social media posts so
let me get this straight okay
now you're going to be checking whose
pictures he's liking
and this is what I mean when I say women
we just like look for problems like I
think sometimes we just like problems
because we go looking for them
um and you know
our grandmothers are great grandmothers
they couldn't help if our husbands were
flirting with the secretary at work and
they didn't go looking for it and that's
like the difference between modern day
chicks and older chicks like modern day
chicks it's like we just want the drama
we just want problems
um so a 2020 study published in
psychological reports found that a lack
of trust in your partner can wreck havoc
in your relationship leading to
emotional instability conflicts and even
the intention to break up what's more
people who don't trust their partners
are more likely to snoop through their
cell phones which can make problems
worse
do you see how okay let's just be honest
guys men aren't really looking through
phones like that it may be more feminine
men do but in general let's just let's
just be honest women are much better
cheaters than men
let's just call it what it is and I know
you can find some study that says men
she more than women but in my opinion
education has just been infiltrated by
feminists and you really can't trust a
lot of these studies but if I go to the
streets and ask the people who cheats
more men or women they usually say women
if I go to the streets and ask the
people who's better liar men or women
it's typically women it's typically
they're they're just typically better
cheaters you know
men it's kind of like
if you catch them
they're like all right all right but the
women they'll deny it to the Grave it's
so funny there was an article in like
the 1900s of a guy who is just so
perplexed by how women when they were
guilty of a crime how they would just
never admit it they would just never
were the men it's like okay when when
the evidence came out they would kind of
they would be like all right I did it
but that's female nature like female
nature is just much more deceptive than
male nature
um but it's just funny because we always
want to hide
the the bad parts of female nature but
we're never we never hide the bad parts
of female nature so it's interesting in
this article because
they're putting the onus of
responsibility on the men because they
say people who don't trust their
partners are more likely to snoop
through their cell phones so it's not
people that snoop through cell phones or
more likely to be crazy it's their fault
right you didn't trust them so it's
their fault that you snooped
rather than jump the gun on the issue
emotionally separate yourself from the
information you just received weigh the
signs that your relationship is strong
happy and fulfilling against the signs
that your partner has one foot out the
door
for instance before you react to the
secret that was kept from you ask the
following questions
how meaningful is this information to
you has your partner ever given you a
reason to doubt their faithfulness have
you ever kept similar secrets from your
partner what was your motivation behind
keeping this information secret from
them
as hard it may as hard as it may be to
hear if your partner is a history of
cheating even the most innocuous
behaviors may fit the description of
micro cheating should be viewed as a red
flag a 2018 study published in the
Journal of in the Journal archives of
sexual behavior found that people who
have cheated in a previous relationship
were three times more likely to cheat
again in a subsequent relationship this
suggests that past infidelity is a
strong prediction of future infidelity
and that some people may have a tendency
to engage in repeated acts of dishonesty
or betrayal therefore if you notice that
your partners frequently texting
flirting or holding things from you and
they have cheated before you may want to
reconsider whether you can trust them
it's so funny though because
most women know
what kind of guy their partner is or
their boyfriend I hate the word partner
um
and it's really interesting because
women will complain about all of these
red flags that we saw before we even
dated
it's like we'll date guys similar to
Chris Brown
Jason Derulo and then cry when we get
cheated on and ladies I just want us as
a group to decide we have no sympathy
none I I just think as a group if you
date a rapper an Entertainer
um and you get cheated on I got I got
nothing for you
um if you date a guy in the top 10
percent of men
um you could date the top 50 percent of
men and not really have top 10 problems
but all these chicks date the top five
ten percent of men in terms of looks in
terms of income and then why when they
get cheated on and I'm sorry guys I'm
not saying it's okay but I really think
we should understand what the
probabilities are when we go into a
relationship and really pick our battles
here
um so I just got no sympathy when you
cry later
when there was like 10 red flags before
the relationship even started so
some learning outside the relationship
is natural according to Gilda zolpolt a
psychologist and the lead author of The
2022 study it's normal to have
attractive Alternatives in one's life
that is not necessarily a threat to your
relationship she noted the individual
can acknowledge that mixed and
conflicting feelings are normal in a
situation that does not mean that the
relationship is necessarily doomed just
that it might require a bit more
attention to sort out one's feelings and
decide the best course of action
whatever that may be you know what's
interesting whenever it's like a female
ver because okay female cheating is a
lot more emotional than male cheating
you know a guy will just find a
a hot chick like it's just like the hot
chick was there right but when women
cheat it's much more emotional tends to
be with a co-worker at work and they
just seem to get their feelings involved
a lot more
um but it's interesting how when she
talks about male cheating she says it's
a red flag but things that are more
associated with female cheating she says
the relationship is not doomed this does
not mean the relationship is necessarily
doomed just that it might require a bit
more attention so she's saying you might
need to put more attention into the
relationship well you know men need sex
women need attention so she's
essentially in this article bailing out
women from female cheating saying that
male cheating is inexcusable now they're
both wrong okay but I'm just really
tired about all this psychology
mumbo-jumbo to just excuse women from
their poor decisions so we have the
conclusion here understanding and
addressing behaviors that border on
infidelity require acknowledging that
there is now a one-size-fits-all
solution the right solution is unique to
you and your partner if you sent Secrets
being kept that cause feelings of
betrayal engage in open dialogue with
your partner clear communication Nation
rooted in empathy and understanding is
the Cornerstone of a long-term
relationship satisfaction so I had this
thought recently I'm like
is communication that important
now I know I know this is like a wild
thought and maybe I'm wrong you know all
of you in the comments but communication
is more of like a female thing like men
don't communicate really to feel better
right they communicate to fix the
problem like what is the problem let's
fix it where women on the other hand you
know we communicate we just want to let
out our emotions so
um essentially when we say clear
communication rooted in empathy and
understanding is the Cornerstone of
long-term relationship satisfaction what
I hear is listen to your woman
yeah that's what I hear like seriously
this is what I hear listen basically
your women's feelings about micro
cheating are valid no matter how stupid
they are so if you see him like an
attractive girls picture on Instagram
your feeling about it is a hundred
percent valid it is a hundred percent
valid to bother him about every feeling
that you have
and he must listen with empathy and
understanding this is what I hear when I
hear this psychology mumbo jumbo
and that's why guys a lot of times I
just don't even really
I I don't really see therapy as like
helping relationships really
um especially when it's a female
therapist it just tends to be do what
the woman wants
um
but you know maybe I'm wrong I'm just a
woman hater big hater so uh topic two
topic two
so
um I was scrolling on Tick Tock last
night and I came across a video of a
woman getting marriage advice from the
anti-suffragettes and this is something
that I really want to push and I really
want people to understand the
anti-suffragettes were not badass women
they were not these they were not even
well liked they typically were women
that hated their husbands they typically
were
um the feminists of today there was no
first wave feminism that was good the
the first the the suffragettes when the
Titanic sank
okay and mind you most of the people
that died on the Titanic were men
eighty percent of the women survived the
majority of the men
died
and the the anti-suffragettes came out
and said If a woman had built the ship
that wouldn't have happened
now does that sound like reasonable
women
and then you you see the common arguing
tactics not all
anti-suffragettes were like that that
was just some no they were planning
assassinations they were planning
bombings
um they were really just
um man haters and women that hated their
husbands and you can see it if you
really look at their writings which
we're going to show now so this is
marriage advice from an anti-suffragette
now let me you guys be the judge let me
let me know if this is good
this is 105 year old marriage advice for
young women from a suffragette you know
the badass women who fought for our
right to vote and let me tell you they
had jokes and I don't know what her
husband did but it could not have been
good let's get into it starting off
strong with do not marry at all but if
you must avoid the beauty men flirts and
the bounders tellers dummies and the
football enthusiasts look for a strong
tame man a fire lighter coal getter
window cleaner and yard swiller don't
expect too much most men are lazy
selfish thoughtless lying drunken clumsy
heavy-footed rough unmanly brutes and
need taming all Bachelors are and many
are worse still if you want him to be
happy Feed The Brute and the same remark
applies to dogs and you would be wiser
not to chance it it isn't worth the risk
so I noticed one choice of words that
the woman used in that and that the
woman used in that video the woman who
wrote it right she said
a man that's easy to tame and it really
goes back to feminists always want to
mess up the natural order of the world
because what what does it mean when you
tame a guy you know as you guys know I
believe there's a natural order in the
world that goes God men women children
and when women try to tame men that
means he's following you you're not
following him and you see her describing
what she wants she wants a weak guy that
she can control and she says don't
expect much and it's so funny because
she she named some pretty like difficult
jobs I would say especially back then
and then goes on to say that the men are
lazy well she's what like writing about
women voting it's so funny it's like I I
just think women project a lot of the
time so it's like a lot of times the
words that we use to describe men and
what men want are really words that
would be better used to describe women
and what we want so I'll give you an
example how many women have said they've
dated a narcissist but in all honesty
guys look at like open your eyes and it
doesn't really matter what the studies
say or whatever I really think we need
to focus on what we see who is more
narcissistic men or women when most
women have a Instagram account with butt
pics on it and most women are very
self-absorbed and you really see this
where women were addicted to social
media and what is social media
everyone's talking to you everyone's
commenting on your information so again
I really think women are much more
narcissistic than men
yet we call them narcissists I think
women are much lazier than men yet she's
calling the guys lazy a lot of times the
the left will come and study study study
and I'm not saying research isn't
important but we
we can't discount what we see in front
of our in front of our eyes and the
modern chick is very entitled The Modern
chick is self-obsessed and this goes
back a hundred years these suffragettes
were not well liked and there's more
women that were opposed to women voting
than were for it and it's really funny
because if you guys look up these
writings the women of the time they talk
about how they didn't like the
anti-suffragettes and they talk about
how this was the beginning of the
breakdown of the family unit and a
hundred years later what have we found
um I think a third of kids now are born
into single mother homes and half
eventually grow up in a single mother
home the family unit is so broken that
couples can't even stay together until
they actually have the child couples
will be broken up when the kid is born
and you know that that's supposed to be
like
you know a good time you're excited you
have the kid and it's like in this
modern era everything is so different
and the anti-suffragettes
predicted this now speaking of modern
relationships and the breakdown of the
family you know I've spoken time and
time again about the nature of women and
the nature of men you know guys there's
a reason we have phrases like a man of
his word right because men just tend to
stick things out more
they tend to do the right thing more
than women I know I know this is this is
never talked about in the mainstream but
but there's a Reason by respect duty
honor or all masculine traits
um and there's a reason why women file
divorce 70 to 80 percent of the time and
it's not the reason that the media will
tell you because it's often when I bring
up these stats I'll say women leave 70
to 80 percent of the time the gut
reaction from the other side from the
left and from even from Trad concerts
well why did she leave because it's
always assumed that women are doing the
right thing and I don't know why it is
always assumed women are doing the right
thing and men are doing the wrong thing
in my opinion it's a hundred years of
propaganda but we see story after story
after Story in the news of women leaving
over nothing
um so today this woman is
thinking about leaving her marriage for
a co-worker pull the clip
my husband and I have been married for
five years and we have three children
together the last three years have been
a nightmare we argue all the time we're
not affectionate as a result I found
myself getting closer to A co-work
A co-worker it wasn't on purpose he
feels a void that I have in my marriage
we haven't been physical but the
emotional connection is so strong I'm on
the verge of leaving my marriage so I
can start over with my co-worker what
should I do oh lord of course things are
going well with your co-worker because
y'all don't have the same complexities
you're not trying to build life together
y'all not trying to run a house together
y'all are not trying to raise kids
together so he doesn't have the same
responsibilities to you as your husband
so don't allow that to fool you to
thinking that if y'all are around each
other all day like you and your husband
are that it's going to be the same
energy understand that only 11 percent
of a Affairs actually turn into
relationships and of those 11 10 of
people who end up getting in a
relationship and getting married 75
percent of those marriages end in
divorce you're looking from the
situation like oh it's so great and he
listens to me he validates me and we
have a great time together it may feel
good to you right now because you're you
have a void and you're not receiving it
from your husband but that's all it is
right it's the feeling the facts are
it's not going to be what you're
thinking is going to be in the long run
wow I actually was pleasantly surprised
look at that I didn't know if they were
gonna bail the chick out or not no that
was actually good advice and this is the
thing
women were told their feelings are valid
um you know they didn't but oftentimes
in the media it's like well we weren't
sleeping together I had a void and and
we live in a society where this woman is
seriously considering leaving three kids
because she has feelings for her
co-worker feelings and that's why I
always say I don't think marriage is
about happiness it's about Duty you know
but we've been we have a generation of
women told that you can leave because
you feel like it
um you have a right to leave for your
happiness it's a me me me culture and
it's interesting because even the fact
that she was willing to write in about
this
shows just how socially acceptable it is
this happens all the time and this also
goes to why men don't want their women
to work because you know it's funny I
should bring up this study but there was
a study that came out a couple of years
ago talking about the most likely
professions to cheat and it's all
professions where women are around High
status men so you know nurses was one of
the number one
um I can't remember the other two or
three but
I just remember it was all when women
were around High status men and it goes
back to women's true nature you know the
peasant
um the peasant's wife will always leave
to be the king's concubine I I don't say
this you know as I'm happy about it I
don't say this as every woman but guys
we have to notice Trends and that's what
I'm trying to get you guys to see like
women we have an inherent nature we have
a nature to be feeling LED we have a
nature to leave marriages when a better
thing comes along we don't have the
nature to stick it out when left to our
own devices and I want to be clear when
left to our own devices you know in the
last hundred years we've had more Choice
than ever and when left to our own
choice uh we tend to leave but when we
submit to men's Authority that's when
you see the great wives the great mother
it's when by listening to you know your
husband or your father whoever it is but
the problem is you know we have a
generation of women that are that are
told we should just do whatever we feel
feel like and our feelings are always in
the right when typically guys
um you know that they're just not so
um next on the list fresh and fit got
demonetized so as you guys know
um I actually am a big fan of Russian
fit so
you know what's funny because in my
early days some of the stuff that Myron
would say would be a bit like triggering
like I think there's some Lefty channels
that have pulled up clips of you know
what because when you first see red pill
advice or red pill
um I guess content it really does switch
your entire world view because you think
the world is one way and it's not so
when I would first hear about for
example guys not wanting to get married
getting married is stupid I would think
well
I I have married parents why is it
stupid but you know when you when it
comes down to it and you look at the
state of that modern chick the state of
the average woman most women have had
sex with multiple men most women uh one
out of three has had an abortion
um one out of you know one out of three
or four has had an STD and it's just
when you start looking at these stats
and realizing that men are just reacting
to the Modern Woman it really puts the
onus on women to become better so men
want to get married again
um but you remember early on
um
yeah I just I just a lot of the stuff
was triggering to hear but then you
watch more and more and you see how much
these guys really do care about men they
they really do and I I genuinely do
believe they save lives because the
information they put out
um they help guys get in better shape
they help guys
deal with women especially modern women
like a lot of guys will say just find a
good woman but you know it's tough in a
society where most women are addicted to
attention the average woman is addicted
to attention the same way a guy would be
addicted to porn right
um but the difference is one is shamed
and one is praise that's that's the
crazy thing so
um yeah I really do believe they're
they're helping save men but recently
this week it came out that fresh and fit
are demonetized so pull the clip
it sucks guys it really does suck
um you know fortunately we know we made
some
moves Etc you know and we kind of saw
knew that the type of content that we
make
for us to be able to give you this
content we have to it comes at a cost it
comes at a cost and it won't be here
forever yeah
always said this you know enjoy us while
you can yeah uh they thought it was
Captain Man yeah if that was a joke and
and you know we did we made moves on the
side knowing that this could potentially
happen and guys we the channel has been
kicked off the YouTube Partner program
just keep it straight away if you look
right now you can't even super chat or
you can't remember chat right now yep uh
so this is the beginning of the end of
this era so we are in trolling chat so
yeah so you literally can't Yeah man so
it's uh so basically
we're we're going to figure out what it
what's going on because we don't even
really know all the details
um we're working with YouTube to try to
come to middle ground and you know work
together and figure this out but for now
we don't even know why we yeah we don't
know the specific
reason
um but we don't in any form fashion
Chris hey YouTuber wanna go at them
we're just saying you know what we wish
we knew the reason why but we respect
you know phenomenon use the platform and
keeping us here for a while and like
yeah you know we appreciate it yeah but
and the thing is is that you guys know
right on this uh pod we push the edge
right we put we push the envelope
there's no we're not going to lie about
that like we give you guys the real deal
when it comes to getting in shape when
it comes to money girls money dating
improving yourself Etc and unfortunately
to be able to give people
real advice that they can take in real
life and apply to the real world
you have to have uncomfortable
conversations about uncomfortable topics
in uncomfortable times guys it's about
to be an election year
you know what I mean we're talking about
certain points and we've brought up
certain points that might not be
politically correct right that might not
necessarily align with everyone's
viewpoints right and we've worked really
hard to bring people on that have
different viewpoints right some of them
very controversial some of them that may
or may not be
um
politically correct
and
that's unfortunately the risk that you
take when you make the kind of content
that we do even other platforms look at
Rumble they're taking a huge beating on
the stock market yeah I mean despite
having one of the best years
revenue and for views and everything and
uh so this comes at a cost no matter who
you are company individual Creator yep
and a lot of you guys want to be
aspiring RB creators as well and I
respect that but just know at a certain
level it will cost you a price you got
to pay and guys we're getting attacked
on at all angles I've been like
whether it's the Press writing articles
on us
videos getting taken down that other
channels are not getting taken down in
the same exact content or whatever it
may be Rubble getting hit right for free
speech uh video like just get strikes
whatever maybe
guys it's gotten to the point now where
even where we shoot the location doesn't
want us to stay here yeah
I didn't want to have to say
that I really don't want to have to
admit that I wanted to just
move the studio support is surprise you
guys yo new studio it's it's lit right
but dude there is like there is a matrix
man like I mean I mean we've talked
about this with Andrew at length like
people don't want you guys to get this
message dude even rumbles under attack
too bro for everybody yeah they're
they're trying nobody should Rumble down
like I think at some point there was
free speech where it was like okay you
know what you see what you got to say we
won't crucify you but nowadays free
speech is kind of like it's a different
thing I mean not really
and you know and I've already put
I've already put a conserve on my on my
uh money into this new studio for you
guys
I already already put it in I'm like all
in you know what I mean and it's uh and
it's okay I'm never gonna say oh oh well
I I I'm I'm doing this blah blah blah
and I hate doing this I love doing this
I'd be lying to you guys if I didn't say
I didn't love doing this I left a job
that I truly loved to do this right
because
thank you
I shouldn't be admitting this but
saving children right
that was great but saving you guys
better
um I wanted to point out a couple things
so
when when men are in a locker room
together
speech is very unfiltered they make they
make stupid jokes they may I mean they I
mean I I don't you know I've never I've
never been in one but I have heard you
know my brothers amongst friends and
it's like as a chick you hear certain
stuff and you're like oh my gosh this is
how guys talk but it's funny because you
know the manosphere is the men's space
on YouTube and it's so interesting
because whenever have men have a space
where they can just talk freely women
feel the need to police it so that's
where you'll get women that come in and
say Well it you it's not it's about how
you say it you need to say it in a more
feminine way is essentially what they're
saying and that's why you can kind of
tell when men are like led by some women
in their lives because they're always
going to come in and say it's your tone
it's the way you say it rather than is
the information correct because women
care about how things are said men care
about if things are true right
um and it's interesting too because Avon
free to do a video about fresh and fit
you know and the title is fresh and fit
are in tears as YouTube Kicks them out
and guys we the channel has been kicked
off the YouTube Partner program I
shouldn't be admitting this but
saving children right
that was great it was saving you guys
better
[Applause]
yeah man this is tough bro
[Music]
this might be one of the last times you
guys hear this intro
if you go to rumble
and it's really interesting to see the
responses of content creators that
when fresh and fit get kicked off
because on one hand they will tell men
to be emotionally available a lot of
these content creators say it's okay to
show your emotions it's okay to be
emotionally available yet when a man
does show his emotion they make fun of
him for it
and this is what they preach and the
next thing that's interesting is a lot
of you know and I'd like to say a lot of
content creators came out
um so as you guys know fresh and fit
about two three years ago had an
instance where a girl was saying that
you had to sleep with them to get on the
show okay that that happened like two
three years ago
and the the issue was I've been preached
it about like 20 videos on fresh and fit
basically
um alluding to Myron being predatory in
some way and what what happened was they
actually they left out a really
important part of the conversation with
that chick where it showed he he was
trying to hook up with her and let her
come on the show look it I'm not that's
like a personal thing but what the truth
of the matter is
they they just believed the chick and
covered her messages and took out all of
the context that would show that Myron
was innocent that he wasn't doing what
they said they they were doing and so
you know in response to this fresh and
fit at the time copyright struck a bunch
of them like they they copyright struck
a bunch of people and people are trying
to say it's the same thing dumb
copywriting because they were
essentially getting me tooed and it's
really unfortunate because as a content
creator you can't really do anything
about it and you know Myron was lucky
because of what he does at the time he
couldn't get fired but anyone in an
average job would just get fired based
on this unfair reporting at the time
um so essentially a lot of people are
celebrating and they view it as as
payback because they copyright struck
you know Myron or Myron copyright struck
a bunch of people years ago
um then the other interesting thing was
that Adam preach copyright struck me and
then when we were going to take it to
court they ended up
dropping it
but it's just it's just really
interesting the double standards and the
space where whenever men are doing
something unapologetically masculine
um they're either they're canceled they
have articles written about them they're
me too
um where when the left does essentially
the same thing you know how many stories
have come out of Destiny sleeping with
someone that he collabed with but nobody
met who's him but it's just interesting
how we see these like double standards
in the space where when a guy does
something that's masculine you know
there there is a Target on his back you
know people are trying to take them down
um and I I just think the most ironic
part of it is the guy saying to be
emotionally available
um are the ones making fun of them for
basically losing something they put two
three years into their life's work and
guys I don't think you
you really understand how much like as
YouTube content creators like our
livelihood goes into this stuff like we
we literally put like a piece of our
soul into this like I I genuinely
believe content is Art
um
and
you know getting demonetized
um is
devastating really to any content
creator so I really I I think you guys
should go support fresh and fit and sign
up to their Rumble if you can it's like
five dollars a month just type in fresh
and fit um on Rumble and the links in
any of any of um we'll put the link in
the description but yeah the but yeah
guys I really we need to support other
red pill content creators men's content
because men do deserve to have a space
where they can talk freely without women
policing them and telling them how to
speak and men do deserve to have content
that represents them and their thoughts
and their opinions without being me too
without having a million hit pieces and
without being canceled on everything
what's happening to fresh and fit what
happened to Andrew Tate what happened to
snico it's all wrong
um and who knows I have no idea if I'll
be next um you know females do get a
privilege online but
it's it's really unfortunate to just see
them take down
um more masculine
content
um that really that really does save
lives so
all right topic five topic five so so
you know one one thing that fresh and
fit and other content creators have
taught me personally being in the space
is that men and women have roles you
know there's different roles for men and
there's different roles for women and
traditional I really think traditional
relationships work the best
I'm not saying that no relationship can
work if it's more modern clearly some do
but you know on a balance of
probabilities traditional relationships
were the men are providing women are
taking care of the home
tend to work the best so Twitter is in
an uproar as you guys know Rachel Wilson
who's a friend and commentator on the
channel had a tweet go viral she said
in the 16 years we've been together my
husband has never done laundry the
dishes cleaned a bathroom vacuumed or
mopped he does not do housework ever at
all
and it's so funny to see you know
um men and women come and attack my
friend Rachel
um because the way that she lives her
life she believes that men and women
have roles and she does not believe that
men are meant to do the dishes that's a
woman's job the man can do the yard work
and so
um Phil says that is fine but it's not a
flex and not something everyone is cool
with so again that's more of a female
arguing pattern you know you'll see like
a woman's gut reaction when we say water
is wet well not all water is wet that's
how women argue so again it's
interesting because you see men that
tend to be led by women and it's usually
either something their wives taught them
or their mothers taught them
um and I I don't know who this guy is so
nothing personal but this is just a
trend that I see with the average guy
they the not all not all when again
that's really more of how women talk so
this is fine but it's not a flex and not
something everyone's cool with but why
because some of us men like to cook and
clean and believe that's a shared thing
so again guys what does that tell us
it's back to the egalitarian principle
men and women are equal and the question
is do you really think men and women are
the same so Hunter Avalon
um said she posted this as a W for her
husband Al Mao yet marriages that share
equal responsibilities tend to last
longer and be healthier and she responds
like yours now I don't know this guy got
into so much
heat on Twitter and I I don't want to
say the ins and outs of it because I
don't know but he he recently got
divorced so that's the funny thing like
the left will prod into our personal
lives and just go on these witch hunts
where it's like what what is your
personal life look like and you know uh
my friend who's been married like 15
years is being lectured by a guy that
just got divorced how she should be do
more chores and this is where I come
back to you know
guys there there are so many you you can
find a study that tells you anything and
it's because women and feminists have
infiltrated institutions and a lot of
these institutions were started by a lot
of the big families that have an agenda
and do not want to see the family unit
Thrive and you know that's why a lot of
times while you know I will quote
studies and leftal quote studies I
really want to drive the point home that
what do we see in real life
uh do women tend to like the nice guys
that just share the equal
responsibilities do they tend to treat
them very well or do women tend to treat
men better that they have to work for do
women tend to treat men better that
um it's more of a traditional
relationship
I mean
look around in the world tell me what
you see so Bree says another comment
responding to my friend Rachel as a
married woman I will say that you are
wrong about what marriage should look
like husbands love your wives just as
Christ loved the church and gave himself
for her do you see this is why men okay
this is why men don't even like
religious women anymore because they
weaponize the Bible to control their
husbands again if the natural order of
the world with God men women children
who are you to tell your husband what to
do
you can ask you can you can give him
your opinion but do you women are
willing to submit to your boss when your
boss tells you something do you quote
him the Bible
no you just listen and
um we've been told these egalitarian
principles were equal were the same when
that's not how it's supposed to work
that's not what marriage is supposed to
be so she says marriage is about
sacrificial love on both sides that
means doing something for someone else
else without being asked because it's
the right thing to do even if you don't
want to your argument that your this man
is Justified when he isn't being
representative of Christ in his marriage
is extremely flawed and telling but it's
nice to know that your idea of a
traditional man is a lazy video game
slob who does nothing helpful and is a
dick to his wife when she asks for help
I assume that's why so many men defend
you and follow you is because you're
broken in cell egos
um tell them what they want to hear you
know what's funny that's like another
cope that you see women say that we all
got millions of followers and Views
because they're just all in cells you
know it's funny how often do we hear
women whine about video games but we
never hear men whine about women being
on social media
it's so funny because I think about this
I'm like I think the men are more
supportive than the women because you
see men taking pictures for their girl's
Instagram on dates but you'll never see
a woman like helping her guy play video
games and and the other interesting
thing is
why is sacrificial love only the love
that she deems sacrificial and why is
her gut reaction when a guy doesn't do
dishes that he doesn't do anything you
know men do yard work they fix things
they build things like men just do
different things and I think it's okay
and really should be encouraged that men
and women have different roles in the
household that that seems to work better
um it's just it's so interesting that
it's like even the Christian women will
weaponize the Bible to control their
husbands but when your your boss gives
you a task you don't
you don't say Ephesians 5 25 no you just
listed but it's so crazy because they'll
listen for money but we won't listen to
a guy that's the father of our of our
kids so
the comments have just been going back
and forth and crazy on this this
couldn't happen with me and my wife her
job is the dishes it's her complete
responsibility I also cannot ask her if
I do the dishes because it's an insult
to the position however if she asks me
to help her do the dishes I will help
because I care enough to do so doesn't
that sound like a partnership I feel
like it works better when we are both
striving to help love and serve each
other yep and when the conflict comes
what happens so guys I want to point
something out
women wanted to work
a lot of women will complain that like
men now we have to have two incomes no
no no no no no no women had the choice
to stay home when we chose to work and
my thing is if you're going to choose to
work please do not complain about the
outcome I've seen women on Tick Tock
that are literal doctors
and she still comes home
and cooks her husband dinner every night
and guys think think about this do you
think most men most husbands if the
woman said I really don't want to work I
want to stay home and be with my kids
genuinely do you think most guys will
say no or do you think most women work
because they want to have a career
uh genuinely so Gia says my husband
doesn't do housework ever and I I
responded I said it actually helps women
to be realistic in our expectations
rather than expect things we cannot have
and she says a hundred percent now you
know the simps come in I hope both of
your significant others help out around
the house in the near future you too can
raise your expectations it takes very
little effort to wash dishes or a load
of laundry no I won't be red pilled I
help my wife around the house when I can
being red pilled means listening to the
philosophies of pickup artists when they
said me man she woman we work she cleans
now you know it's interesting I think
the average screen time of a chick is
like six seven hours a day
so it's like okay if we find the time to
go on our phones for like six hours a
day we can't find the time to cook to
clean
um you know and this isn't saying the
husband can never help you most men are
willing to help but the idea is that you
are supposed to serve your husband that
is the role of the wife the help mate
and yet women will expect their husbands
to work full-time and serve their every
feeling their every need and that's not
how it's supposed to work no I don't
like waking up to a dirty kitchen who
cares I care all right I care I busted
my ass all day cleaning this house and
then cooking that meal and I work today
it would be nice if you said Thank you
and helped me with the dishes
fine I'll help you do the damn dishes oh
come on you know what no that's see
that's not what I want you just said
that you want me to help you do the
dishes I want you to want to do things
why would I want to do dishes
why see that's my whole point
are you telling me that you're upset
because I don't have a strong desire to
clean dishes no I'm upset because you
don't have a strong desire to offer to
do the dishes I just did after I asked
you Jesus Brooke you're acting crazy
again don't you call me crazy I am not
crazy I call you crazy I didn't call you
quick no I didn't I said you're acting
crazy you know what Gary I asked you to
do one thing today one very simple thing
to bring me 12 lemons and you brought me
three if I knew that it was going to be
this much trouble I would have brought
home 24 limits even 100 I know what I
wish I wish everyone that was at that
goddamn table had their own little
private bag of lemon it's not about the
lemon that's all you're talking about
I'm just saying it'd be nice if you did
things that I asked it would be even
nicer if you did things without me
having to ask you
I do seem to remember doing something
for you this morning without you asking
Carrie come on no I'm serious I really
am come on you knew I was working today
and I made that meal and you could have
thought to yourself you know you could
have said you know I think I'm gonna
give Brooke some flowers
you said on our very first date that you
don't like flowers if they're a waste of
money
when women try to control men I'm
serious guys you know
does that does that look like she's
submitting to his authority
when she's whining that he he brought 12
lemons instead of three like okay maybe
it's annoying but it's not the end of
the world and we caused these like big
fights over what lemons and it's so it's
so funny because women tend to work
longer than men but we never take that
into account where men tend to have
harder jobs men tend to work longer
hours where it's like I mean I think she
was like an art gallery person in this
video in this movie
so all right like you know and what was
I gonna say um
oh and it's so funny because she says
can you help me do the dishes and then
she puts on a fuss and this is the
problem guys like get into when they
constantly like agree to women after we
put on a fuss because it just shows us
that we can like control you because now
she knows every time she she's
gonna get her way now the interesting
thing is though
she he does what she asks and is she
happy no you're not doing it in the way
that I want you to do it and then she
says on the first date no I don't like
flowers he doesn't buy her flowers now
she's mad he didn't buy her flowers and
it's just
you know that aren't mind readers and I
think a lot of times you know again we
get so frustrated because we expect
things that we shouldn't expect from men
so in this she's expecting him
to behave like a woman and he's not a
woman and and we're going to constantly
have relationship problems if we keep
expecting men to be women and
communicate like women and read between
the lines like women they're not women
they're never going to be women and the
more we try to control men and impose
our will upon men
um I just think the worst relationships
are getting and I think that's what
we've seen in the last hundred years
you'll see clips from like 60 70 years
ago where a woman says he's the boss
um does that seem like she refers to him
as the boss and you know men men feel
like this they feel demasculated over a
long period of time and it's really sad
to see what happens over 30 40 50 years
of this this is why you know honestly
ladies this is why men are walking away
from Marriage they don't want a lifetime
of women telling them what to do and how
to do it and if they listen they're
never happy this is what a lot of men
are signing up for and until we as women
you know improve our attitudes and offer
more to men we're going to keep seeing
them walking away from our relationships
walking away from marriage and you see
that in clips of like of guys that
choose not to be in a relationship is
they don't want a girl telling them what
to do all the time so
you know women are we're so addicted to
attention these days we have to put into
context that women are rewarded for
getting attention from other men imagine
if men were rewarded for watching porn
how off the rails would they be but
that's what you see in media nowadays
remember women are addicted to attention
so a supermodel actually died after
hitting a Lamppost while hanging out of
her car window so there was a video I
saw on Twitter of and we're gonna have
to blur this or something but of a chick
naked hanging out of a car
[Music]
oh
God yeah and that's so sad like it's
it's sad to me that you know a hundred
years ago 50 years ago that would have
been a wife a mother but she became so
attention addicted that it literally led
to her death that's why we see these
chicks like
or that's why we see like women on their
phones not even watching their kids like
really well the equivalent of the
average tick on the market today is
equivalent to a guy addicted to porn
um imagine that a guy was so addicted to
porn that he literally died and we see
case after case after Kate we see this
as a trend a growing Trend more women
getting so addicted to social media that
they ruin their marriages you know they
don't watch their children and they
literally die for attention
um so I think before you know we go with
the men we really have to look in the
mirror and say uh what what does the
average woman offer the average man
nowadays so you know guys um and I think
we gotta identify Trends so let me know
what trends you see happening in society
and let me know
um what you want me to cover tomorrow on
Pearl daily make sure you like the video
on your way out and subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time